Tout était en place pour une mission
sans faille. Les deux astronautes,
l'américain Nick Hague et le russe Alexeï Ovtchinine, un vétéran, sont montés à bord
souriants. Il faisait beau quand le
décompte a commencé. Un décollage parfait
Puis,  en plein vol, alors que la
fusée s'apprêtait à entrer en orbite
vers la station spatiale
un signe de détresse a été lancé.
Moteur en panne, atterrissage d'urgence inévitable.
Le vaisseau a dû effectuer un retour sur
Terre en mode balistique, c'est-à-dire
presque en chute libre.
« C'est chute libre absolument pas
contrôlée et c'est vraiment c'est comme
un crash de voitures. » Pour les
observateurs comme Christine Chapelle le suspense a été court, mais pénible
de la tour de contrôle à Baïkonour jusqu'à la NASA,
c'était le silence radio. La capsule a
fini par atterrir dans les steppes du
Kazakhstan. Les deux hommes sains et saufs mais secoués.
Ils sont sous observation. « Ils sont en bonne forme. »
L'astronaute canadien Chris Hadfield
pense surtout à ses confrères qui
habitent la station spatiale depuis des mois.
« Il reste trois astronautes, un Américain, un Allemand et un Russe, en orbite. »
« Ils attendent un autre équipage et donc ils sont seuls. » Et personne ne sait combien temps
ils le resteront.
« Ils ont un vaisseau qui peut en trois
heures les ramener sur Terre.
Après, si on veut renvoyer des
astronautes dans l'espace,
là il faut qu'on trouve ce qui s'est
passé ce matin. Tant qu'on ne sait pas, on ne peut pas faire repartir une fusée. »
Le gouvernement russe a suspendu tous les
vols habités jusqu'à nouvel ordre.
Le prochain était prévu le 20 décembre.
Il devait transporter le canadien David
Saint-Jacques qui était à Baïkonour ce
matin à titre de doublure pour l'équipage
qui a échoué. « La vie de David Saint-Jacques  est changé aujourd'hui. »
Et c'est l'avenir de la station spatiale
qui est en jeu, dit cet expert.
« C'est la première fois depuis l'an 2000
que la possibilité que la station
spatiale soit désertée, inoccupée est
bien réelle. Car la Soyouz est non
seulement la fusée la plus fiable de
l'histoire, elle est aujourd'hui la seule
qui peut transporter des humains vers la
station internationale.
Les Russes devront maintenant rassurer
leurs partenaires comme la NASA, mais
l'incident d'aujourd'hui met aussi
énormément de pression sur des
compagnies comme Boeing qui tardent à
livrer la prochaine génération de fusées
aux Américains. Ici Tamara Altéresco, Radio-Canada, Moscou.